malevolent is a 2018 and Netflix
original horror movie the film follows a
group of charlatans psychics that find
themselves on the wrong side of a
paranormal investigation there's a lot
to unpack from the film's ending and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the plot of malevolent in full detail
there will be heavy spoilers so make
sure you stop this video now if you want
to go into the film with fresh eyes
without the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to set
in 1986 the film follows a group of
paranormal investigators that make a
living from making exorcisms and psychic
occurrences led by brother and sister to
you our Jackson and Angela the group are
persuaded to take a job outside of their
comfort zone when Jackson gets in over
his head with the wrong crowd and owes
debts travelling to a house far in the
countryside where several murders and
strange occurrences have taken place the
group soon discovered that the location
is actually haunted and the midsection
of the movie is made up of them
attempting to get to the bottom of the
mystery that surrounds the estate
overseen by the enigmatic mrs. green the
house becomes a character itself and
throws a range of specters in spirits
the group's way their pain how it's rich
in troubled history whilst the group
begin by faking their exorcisms as the
movie progresses Angela and Jackson
discover that they are in fact psyche
these abilities have been passed on from
their grandmother and mother and allow
them to see visions of the spirits that
inhabit the house when traversing the
house Angela sees visions of young girls
with their mouths sewn shut and during a
run with cameraman Elliot discovers a
hidden room where the girls were kept
and tortured after this event mrs. green
confronts Jackson and calls him out for
being a psychic scammer
she also divulges that her son was the
one who murdered the girls and that she
consented to the act of sowing their
mouths shut because they were little
monsters that wouldn't be quiet
Jackson immediately calls off the
cleansing and attempts to leave however
when his girlfriend Beth goes missing he
calls for one final search of the house
so that no one is left behind Jackson
finds Beth with her mouth sewn shut and
the group attempt to leave in their car
unfortunately Jackson crashes it when he
believes he
he's a girl standing in the middle of
the road and Beth is killed Jackson has
taken back to the house by mrs. Green's
son Herman Elliot is left unconscious
and Angela must pick up the pieces with
Elliot out of action
Angela returns to the mansion to get a
brother back with the help of the
spirits of the young girls she is able
to track Jackson down Angela is captured
and wakes up to find herself bound to a
chair Jackson has been tortured by mrs.
green and her son and has had his tongue
cut out and his mouth sewn together it's
a horrifying scene to watch that really
elevates this movie above your typical
Netflix horror Elliot wakes up and
returns to the house where he manages to
kill mrs. green son before being
brutally attacked by mrs. green herself
Angela helpless to aid him calls out to
the spirits to help her friend and they
scream out which gives Angela enough
time to free herself and stab mrs. green
killing her once in parole Angela leaves
the grounds to find Jackson walking
along unharmed and looking for Beth it's
at this point that we realized that he
has sadly passed away and it's now ghost
a passing car stops to help Angela and
the film ends with Angela in the
hospital and Elliot on the road to
recovery we see Angela in the final
scene on the phone to her grandfather
who say she can't be left alone at this
point and Angela triumphantly states
that she's not alone as a comforting
shadow passes over her it's never
confirmed who this is but personally I
believe that it's Jackson who has
returned as we do learn that the two
were twins well so we never get the full
reasoning of why mrs. green committed
the acts she hints at the girls
disobeying her when all she tried to do
was be a mother to them because of this
she celled their mouths shut
left empty staff mrs. green is horrified
when the group entered the East Wing of
the house as she knows that there is a
high probability that they will discover
the secret room where the murders took
place mrs. green mentions wolves at her
door which is a clear allusion to the
fact that the press outed her son
clearly she made him take the fall and
is very domineering there's a clear sign
that she is passing on the qualities of
her mother who abused her as a child
it's clear that the events are car make
to the group as they preyed on the weak
and vulnerable for profit much in the
same way that mrs. green preyed on the
and defenseless there's a clear
collusion between the insanity of the
mother mrs. green and the insanity of
Jackson and Angela's mother who took her
own life after being unable to handle
the visions this is a film about how
committing wicked acts leaves us to be
haunted by them and the film definitely
has a lot going on beneath the surface
so what did you think of malevolent who
do you think the shadow was and what's
your favorite part of the film comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please make sure to give
us a thumbs up and subscribe to our
channel if you love film make sure you
check out my breakdown of Halloween at
the end of this one and thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you